- This is a big idea, Jord.
Biz Dev Sundays.
Here we go.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
It's almost 8 o'clock at night.
It's been a weird, weird day.
About to workout with Jordan.
Just passed the laundry room.
Heard people yelling.
Guy yelled the score.
I can't believe the
Falcons are winning 21-nothing.
I tried not to know
anything about the game or
watch anything about it.
So my prediction is Pats win.
Anyway, woke up this
morning on one hour's sleep.
Slept the whole flight.
Landed, hung out a little bit.
Had to take a nap.
Just dead.
I just woke up.
What a weird day.
Just a weird, weird day.
But looking forward to workout
and came up with a little fun
idea for Sundays so
I'll record that in a minute.
It's called Biz Dev Sundays.
This is a big idea, Jord.
So I'm gonna do Biz Dev Sundays.
What I'm gonna do on Sundays
is list things for you the
community of things that I'm
up to that might be business
opportunities for me and you.
Now, the thing that scares
me about this and why I don't
normally do this is
I get tons of emails,
like hundreds, that have
nothing to do with it, right?
People are trying
to really stretch.
Move in Jordan, I want
to make sure you hear this.
You know, like really stretching
if they're actually can do this
or whatever I'm asking
for is really a fit but
hopefully it works out.
So, actually, you
know what let's do
bizdevsunday@VaynerMedia.com.
Team, create that email.
This way it won't be horrible
and this way a bunch of the team
can jump in to the
email with me and forward it.
So, right, first, the
first Biz Dev Sunday item,
oh, crap Jordan your phone.
Oh I got it.
Small brands to do
stuff with my athletes.
Right, so VaynerSports
as you guys know,
one of the things I'm trying to
do is change that sport a little
bit and do
endorsement deals that have
never been done before.
Obviously, the Nikes and Under
Armours and Adidas and Reebok
deals, the Panini Sports Cards.
Those are all standard deals
that we'll work with and a lot
of that has to do with where
the kid's coming out of school.
Like those are slotted in
and we negotiate them but
I want to do unique things.
Up and coming brands, right?
Like nose stripes or
headbands or beanies
or socks or granola bars
or trail mix or, you know,
pomegranate juice or
coconut water
before they were big.
This is a real opportunity for
my athletes that are gonna have
big social media profiles become
new star rookies in their cities
and big college stars, you know
like Jaylen Reeves-Maybin and
Jon Toth from
Kentucky and Tennessee.
Now you're thinking about if
you're regional play in
middle America and you want to
hit that fan base of them being
college stars and
now they go to the pros.
So these are things that I'm
looking for so if you are a
startup brand, T-shirt brand
and you're willing to pay a
small amount of dollars to my
players to be one of the faces
of your brand and
put it on their social
or we create content and you put
it on your social, or if you
want to get a piece of the
equity of the
company for those guys,
kind of that Vitamin Water deal
that David Wright got
and 50 Cent got.
Biz dev, small brands with my
up-and-coming athletes and some
of the athletes that we're
building around VaynerSports is
today's Sunday first Biz Dev #1.
("Right Now" by Bazanji)
Alright, number two on
the Biz Dev Sunday list,
by the way, this thing.
What the hell is that, Jordan?
- [Jordan] It's
called a Valslide.
- Okay, whatever.
I hate it.
(Jordan laughs)
Number two,
stickers and posters.
If you're a company and by the
way we'll put like stickers and
posters, biz dev for brands, so
put whatever we put down here in
the title when you send it to
the email so that way we don't
have any confusion in whoever is
jumping in and handling it can
go through it quicker.
Sticker and posters.
Stickers and posters.
Obviously the things that create
T-shirts and all the quotes and
the stuff on Instagram all that
stuff so many people asking for
stickers and posters.
I'm looking for
a company or two,
a startup that
wants to biz dev with me.
What I'm looking
for is starting at free,
that's the best deal for the
exposure and all the different
people all the
way up to whatever
I think the best deal is.
That's where we biz
dev, what's the value prop,
what's the exchange?
I know that people
get so sad about free.
If I had a sticker and
poster company where I printed,
I would pay somebody
that had a big audience and
be willing to do it.
I did it a ton
with Gourmet Library.
Gave away free cheese forever.
I did it with my baseball cards
when I was 15 I gave away free
cards to the biggest dealers
and thing because it made
relationships and I built on
that but that's a different
story for a different day.
What's the best deal?
Who's got a sticker company,
big shoutout to Sticker Mule,
done a bunch of stuff with you
in the past but really this is
Biz Dev Sunday.
This is for me and my community
to do business together if we
think we can match.
And so, sticker and poster
companies that are willing to
print on demand and ship to the
people on the other side of this
camera because one of the
biggest things I want to do with
the 60 Second Club,
which I'm rebirthing.
Five minute club.
60 Second club
back on Instagram.
Put on your notifications.
I want to give away a bunch of
the posters and stickers of that
quote in realtime and I think
that would be a lot of fun.
So stickers and posters.
Number three is I just mentioned
the 60 Second Club is back.
I'm focused on it.
I'm putting
people on my team on it.
One of the reasons I faded out
and created a five minute club
was 'cause I was
worried that I couldn't get
in to all the comments.
Thought it would
give me some more time.
Big thing is I just
wanted to deliver on this.
You know, I'm a big fan
of surprise and delight.
Right?
The thing I did the
other day with Chipotle.
I love this stuff.
I call it the
Taylor Swift thing.
I just like doing nice things
that are fun for the community.
Like if Macho Man, did this
back in the day and he had an
Instagram account I would put
my notifications on and when he
would post I click if that gave
me a Face Time with him or a
signed shirt, it
would have been cool.
So anyway, none the less, 60
Second Club if you don't know
what it is, when I
post something on Instagram,
if you like and comment
within the first minute,
you become eligible for me or
somebody in my team now 'cause
I just needed to add that to
make sure that I deliver,
to jump in, pick one, two, three
random people each time to win.
We leave it in the comments, you
DM the information to my team,
we ship out stuff.
Just a fun little thing for
the community and a great way to
make sure that you're keeping
up with those two to three posts
I'm doing every
day on Instagram.
60 Second Club back,
focused, be a part of it.
Alright, I'm starting to get
rocked on my workout here.
Not happy with you Jordan.
You're like all happy.
I want to start
a beanie company,
I've decided.
A brand new beanie company.
Not like GaryVee signature,
not a GaryVee shop,
I mean just like
a beanie company.
So I'm looking for somebody who
is really great at sourcing high
quality
materials for production.
And so I'm looking for somebody
to give a little piece of equity
to to come and be
on my team on this.
Be on my partner.
A creative director
to design the concept.
Got a good idea of what I want
to do but for that person to
make it better and
somebody on the sourcing.
I'll take care of
the design and marketing,
website, all that.
Distribution I think I could
figure out pretty quickly but
somebody to actually
produce the first 10,000.
Gonna start a beanie company
'cause I wear them all the time
and I miss retail.
Want to sell something.
And something that's not like
hustle your fucking face off.
Cool, who wants to be
part of the beanie company?
Hit me up.
Now, delete it yet?
Perfect.
Not I've got hustle and
I need to be a part of this.
You have experience in producing
product that has been sold at
retail, direct to consumer in
the fashion space and you have a
creative director
background around it as well.
Experience only.
Young hustlers, we got a many
million things to do with you
but this one
that's what I need
so don't waste
your time or mine.
And finally,
sorry, I'm not getting up.
And finally, clip it,
clip one, clip one minute.
Clip it whatever
we want to call it.
We'll come up with
the hashtag, just clip it.
In the YouTube
section's comments,
your favorite one minute clip
from every DailyVee that we
can then use for an Instagram,
Facebook and Twitter video.
So a new group of people who
follow DailyVee who when they
watch the episode
say #ClipIt 2:13 to 3:13.
We're gonna use the community to
decide which clips we should be
making in our
one minute Instagram,
Facebook and Twitter videos.
Who's part of the
clip it community?
Let me know in the comments.
How long?
- 47.
- 12 60s.
- Alright.
- 60s for a minute 12.
- Farmer's carries?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I'm still
not strong there though.
- Stronger just not
stronger than you wanted.
- One is greater than zero.
Worst workout every.
See you tomorrow.
("Right Now" by Bazanji)